[Music]
okay 1982 that's the highest rated we've
faced by far
let's see let's go d4 let's go very
positional against this guy oh in an
england
okay
so a lot of people i think want to know
how to play against this so let me try
to prove my uh
you know
put my my my mouth where my money is my
money where my mouth is oh my god i'm
i'm tired
okay so we obviously accept it
and uh we defend the pawn with knight f3
and now there are two main moves yeah so
queen e7 is the is the tricky move
and
the england is one of those openings
where there is a quote-unquote trap
but the best line is precisely to fall
into the trap
uh and does anybody know what i'm
talking about yeah so queen e7
counter-attacks the pawn
and the quote-unquote trap is to go
either bishop f4
or bishop g5 in both of those moves
essentially transpose into the same
overall line so you can play bishop
bishop f4 anyway
now the reason that this is considered
to be quote-unquote falling into the
trap is because it allows queen before
check
forking the king and the bishop
however after queen before check we can
return with the bishop and block on d2
but it appears that black simply takes
the pawn on b2
and it seems that we're in huge trouble
the rook on a1 is hanging blacks won the
pawn back i mean how
bad could it get
and yet if you know this line well if
you know the theory you will realize the
fact that black is so underdeveloped and
that the queen is deep in white's grill
so early in the game is not a good thing
for black and it turns out that in fact
black is almost losing in the main line
bishop d2
queen takes b2 attacking the rook
now the actual trap is that the very
tempting move is bishop c3 you think let
me attack the queen and x-ray defend
rook but bishop c3 is wrong on account
of what move
bishop c3 is a big mistake on account of
bishop b4 bishop swoops in
pinning white's bishop to the king
and that creates very problematic
consequences for white therefore you've
got to play knight c3 that is correct
thank you yartran bishop b4
and now what is the key continuation and
amman
and i think the chess bras have analyzed
this this is a very famous queen
sacrifice line you go rook b1 and black
plays queen takes c3 no queen a3 okay
queen a3 is not is not challenging uh
queen takes c3
is uh the way that i think amman
recommended this and i will show you
guys afterward how to get a big
advantage in that line
now queen a3 as far as i remember is
just very very bad
uh for several different reasons
uh to my
understanding i think knight d5 is an
excellent move here
immediately going after the c7 pawn you
basically don't want a dilly dally i
will check this after the game guys just
to make sure i'm not lying to you
but uh as far as i remember
knight d5 is the move here offering the
trade of bishops then you just play
queen takes d2 and that threat against
against the c7 pawn is absolutely
devastating look at how underdeveloped
black is you just can't get away with
this kind of stuff in chess
if you go knight d5 well if he goes
queen a5 we just take the bishop the
bishop is attacked one two three times
and only defended one twice oh my god he
did it
who's the prophet here i'm supposed to
be the prophet you're uh stealing my
thunder my man
okay so he's wondering he's wanted a
piece
we can play bishop takes before or night
takes before which way do you guys think
we should take you got to be careful you
have to be creative
one of these moves is a pretty big
mistake
yeah we should definitely take with a
knight
uh the problem is that if you take with
a bishop
after knight takes b4 do you guys see
how the queen is going to be pinning
whatever piece appears on v4
um
and
that's going to be an issue because
black will be able to play c5 after that
and pick that piece off so knight takes
b4 is crucial
taking it with the rook would be bad
because that d5 knight was was also
hanging by by the queen
okay so takes takes
now i'd like to take with a bishop to
prevent him from castling
and now how do we continue in this
position again
very often players get over creative or
too fancy you don't need to do either
you simply need to follow
the rules of development you need to
complete the development which means we
need to get this bishop out to get the
bishop out we need to bring the pawn out
to e4 thank you for being generous
stingy californian
appreciate it
yes he's probably going to go a5
i guess would be he's going to go a5
he's going to try to dislodge the bishop
from this diagonal which is which would
be completely understandable
knight h6 okay so instead he develops
his knight
now we have a couple of different
approaches here we can also try to trap
his queen
which would be
quite an interesting
way to to try to win the game fast
i mean the simplest move here is is just
to play a bishop d3 but should be two
just develop the bishop and castle
but if we want to go after his queen if
we want to play clinically
we need to figure out
where the queen's escape routes lie and
really there is only one crucial escape
route to cover right that is queen e6
all other squares
in black side of the board are covered
either by the bishop which is covering
the dark squares
or by you know the rook or by this
bishop so
how should we prevent queen e6 without
ruining our position
can we control the e6 square by one of
our pieces
yeah so c4 would be a a an
understandable idea but remember that c4
blocks the bishop's coverage of a6 so c4
covers one of the escape routes but
opens up another
okay so some of you guys are thinking
about knight g5 but generally speaking i
want to orient my pieces toward the
center i don't necessarily want to put a
knight on the side of the board just to
cover e6 so i prefer the move knight d4
of course
um i saw knight g5 i just didn't like it
i know i saw knight e5 both moves are
approximately equivalent but i like my
knight to be toward the center here
maybe it'll go to b5
uh and and you can you can do other
stuff with this knight not just drop the
queen
okay
so what now
again now there's a million different
ways to win
i think if we want to stick to the
original idea of trapping the queen we
should already first check the move rook
a1 so who can tell me this does rook a1
trap the queen should we go over k1
no because queen b2 happens so
at this point b2 is literally the only
escape square for the queen so we need
to think very methodically can we cover
the b2 square with another one of our
pieces so that after we play rook a1
the queen is going to be trapped as soon
as you ask yourself the question that
way the move queen c1 comes to mind
but if you didn't ask yourself that
question it would be hard to generate
this move out of the blue if you didn't
know what you were looking for so that's
why i'm such a big believer at this
higher level of of asking yourself the
right questions
uh we don't care about c5 because we
still are going to go rook a1
now bishop c3 commits the same mistake
that that c4 would have in this position
you are indeed covering one of the
squares but you are opening up another
trapping the queen is generally a very
delicate mechanism there's a lot of
squares that you have to cover a lot of
pieces are involved so you got to make
sure that when you're covering one
square or a set of squares you're not
also opening up another escape route
that's exactly what bishop c3
uh is guilty of because after bishop c3
he can go queen a3 and try to escape via
this diagonal and that wouldn't be a big
deal
one piece of advice is if you're up a
queen in a position like this
don't lose on time trying to trap his
queen if you don't trap his queen that's
not a big deal you're up a piece so you
need to manage your time well queen a4
he's trying to escape
but notice how the queen has literally
no prospects here we have a very simple
move sending the queen back as many of
you guys are indicating it is bishop to
be five yes
queen a2 and then rook a1 traps the
queen
simple
and uh notice how many pieces all hands
on deck effort how many pieces are
involved one two three four five that's
how many pieces are required in order to
trap a man's queen
he resigns
but of course after queen a2 rocket one
the queen is
ten bucks from dual this thank you
i've discovered your stream recently and
i really enjoyed this educational part
of it thank you so much i appreciate it
i'm very happy to hear that
all right
so let me i have a file here um so let
me just quickly open up my chest space
file thank you gigahertz for the seven
months i appreciate it
um
thank you thank you
okay
so let me see just one second
yeah just give me give me a hot second
guys
okay
so um
let's talk about the england
now uh
if you want to play the england i think
uh relatively speaking probably it's a
better idea to play it with d6
this is one of the ways to
to play the england the england is a
very bad opening uh
even compared to other gambits
it's just not good um if white knows
what to do black's position is in
in crisis i mean it's just very very bad
and after d6
um e takes d6 is okay for black i mean
black can try to play this
but white has the very strong sort of
intermediate move bishop to g5 here
and the point of this move
is that if black covers with the bishop
then you're able to trade the bishops
now notice how the d6 pawn has been
softened up and you can simply play e
takes d6 and
black not only is a pawn down but now
he's left with this isolated pawn
there's zero compensation or as we like
to say white's up upon and white has the
compensation
so black has to play the move f6 also
quite ugly
ef6 sorry not gf6 but of course knight
f6
and black can try some stuff with the f
file getting open like bishop b7 and
castle but if white knows what to do
here and how to position the pieces
uh this is just crap i mean why i can
play e3
then get the bishop out and get the
night out quite intuitive here so the
computer evaluates this is like plus
1.70 which is a very very big advantage
even for an unsound gambit
okay
but of course the the juicy line is
queenie sep
the juicy line is is queen e7
um
now looking at reference there's
over a thousand games here this is
extremely well studied
this was first played amazingly
uh in a game
by alexander alakayan alakhine
was white he was giving a simul in i
think
indonesia where's surabaya
where's surabaya
surprise alakai made it to indonesia is
that
wow that's pretty cool
indonesia so alakain had this in a
symbol against indonesia against
indonesia in indonesia in 1933
against some guy named dinger and then
the second time that this occurred was
also in 1933
by uh none other than paul kerris charis
played this with black and it was a
young charis uh like a 16 year old
charis and he got crushed
and both alec and karis's opponents
quite amazingly uh had the wherewithal
to play bishop f4 and go precisely into
the main line so they both
uh played like this
and like this and both of them won white
won both games
then it was played many many times by
henry grubb
of 1g4 fame
so a lot of good players in england only
played in like the 1970s so as usual
uh these openings often get their names
not from the first person who played
them
but because of some sort of book that
was written or article that was or maybe
england played it the most number of
times
now um after bishop b4 and i should
point out there is also the move knight
to b4
yeah fritz england
um it's not like england it's fritz
englund i i don't know how to pronounce
it
so after night before you have to know
white smooth because black is
threatening c2 does anybody know yeah so
curious you're absolutely correct knight
d4 is key
and some of you may be thinking but wait
a second what if black plays c5 and
tries to dislodge the knight now of
course you're not just going to
obediently move the knight from d4
you're going to play
the move rook b1 white's already winning
the queen has only one square
a3
and uh
it says a lot that the computer
recommends taking on b1 this is how bad
things are now you go knight tb5
queen a5 a3 this is all very simple
knight c6 knight t5 and then knight c7
the game is over
so you can see how terrible some of
these lines are but you got to know
knight d4 that's an important move
bishop before rook b1
and the topical line is queen takes c3
amon even played this in a classical
game against my good friend grandmaster
steven zierk in a tournament in san luis
and made a draw
and the funny thing is that at first
sight
this line
uh does not look
that bad for for black
because you know black has two pieces
for
a rook and a couple of pawns and you
know that bishop seems to be very active
now there are five games in my database
with knight takes e5
which loses
very very quickly
the problem with knight takes e5 is that
this bishop on c3 while it looks to be
strong is actually very vulnerable who
can tell me how we can target this
bishop using the resources at our
disposal
white has a series of very nice moves
here so we start with rook b3 good job
and after bishop to a5
uh we continue on with a really sexy
move queen shifts on over to a1
attacking the undefended knight
now if black plays knight c4
then we simply take on g7
we don't give a damn about that knight
because we're gonna win that rook and
win the game
and if black plays d6
then we hunt down the bishop with rook
to b5 we're basically trying to get
black
to take on d2 the more
uh
you know all trades are obviously
favorable for white
and if black plays b6
uh then
we simply sacrifice on a5 and follow up
with what crushing move here
yeah i read your mind yvonne
f4 get out of there mr knight knight g6
queen takes g7
look at this this is a crushing position
white is up a queen and also crushing
so this is game over
and so knight e5 loses essentially on
the spot amman's move is bishop takes e5
this is a relatively speaking better
and what you have to know if you reach
this position
is that white needs to push the e pawn
and steven
okay so
steven played one of the possible moves
you could play e3 and you could play e4
according to my analysis e3 is the best
move that is what steven played
amman responded with the very natural
knight to f6
this is zirc hamilton st louis 2019 and
here steven started to go wrong
he played a very
natural developing move bishop to b5
but somehow
which is still completely winning
oh no no xerox beat hamilton sorry sorry
my bad they played two games in this
line uh in 2018 they drew in 2019 zirk
actually won so steven improved on this
but the funny thing is that there is an
even stronger move in this position
which i think basically wins the game on
the spot
and that is a computer generated novelty
uh the move g4
basically trying to push g5 and put
black out of commission
right off the bat
the secondary purpose of this move is to
prepare the fiance of the bishop to g2
i think this move basically wins the
game on the spot it's plus four
according to the computer
if black delays the pawn with h6 you
simply go bishop g2
then knight comes out to c4 you go h3
white is up a queen black is not enough
compensation
the rook is delaying the development of
black's bishop so this is clearly
insufficient comp for the queen
and that is my analysis so
uh there is not much else to really talk
about in queen take c3 queen to a3 is
relatively speaking a better move than
queen takes c3 i think
um
queen a3 is relatively speaking a better
move but it doesn't solve
any of the problems in black's position
black is still completely lost
knight d5
uh was our move we can also play rook b3
uh so knight t5
uh and the move bishop takes d2 check
okay so queen a5 of course blunders the
piece and there's nothing left to
analyze after that
uh relatively speaking the best line and
this will show you how ugly it is is
taking
king d8 you have no other way to defend
the pawn
you have no other way to defend the pawn
and what's very important to understand
in such positions right you turn on the
computer
and you see plus minus three it's plus
three or plus three point five and you
might be looking at this position and
saying okay i get that white is
attacking but is it really that winning
uh and the answer to that is yes but not
because
and this is an important point not
because there's necessarily a forced win
or some sequence of moves where you know
you may boom boom boom and white is
winning on the spot it's just the fact
that black is so paralyzed and the
attack in the long run is so
overwhelming
um
that if white can play patiently and
bring all of his pieces out then black
is eventually going to be completely
lost it's a matter of time before
black's position collapses
but the thing to understand is that
there is no force to win you just gotta
play patiently now what does it mean to
play patiently in a position like this
how should white develop his pieces
of their pieces
why e3 but why so timid if you're
already pushing the ipon you know i want
the full shebang i want the full nine
yards play e4
at this point there are four games in
the database
now okay but levy levy was trolling
now you might be looking at this and
saying wait a second queen takes a2 why
are we giving up a pawn
do i look like i care about pawns in a
position like this with a knight that is
this dominant a king that is this weak
a center that is this um
superior the answer is no we just play
rook d1
if black attempts to trade queens with
queen a5
then we refuse the trade with c3
um this is some correspondence game from
2012.
our next moves are either going to be
queen g5 which is already a huge threat
or we're simply going to go bishop c4
castles and we're going to crash through
along the d-file look at the center look
at white's pieces the game is over
for instance
i analyzed knight g7
and now the queen swoops into g5 pinning
the knight
rook to g8 is the most sensible moves
defending pawn on g7 and now perhaps the
most destructive move of the attack now
you're ready guys this is going to be an
insane sacrifice i mean you just got to
make sure your seat belts are fast and
you're sitting on your chair this is
going to be the most insane move of all
time wait for it
there should be two
i was trolling
that's precisely the point here is you
simply develop your pieces and black is
so paralyzed that there is nothing he
can do against dwight completing his
completing their development and then
playing like rook d2 rook fd1
and and basically winning the game
um
yeah exactly the insanity of this move
is
hard to comprehend
so
[Music]
if h6 and queen h4 there's no way to
dislodge the queen
because if you go g5 then you drop the
pawn on h6
um
does that make sense i mean i don't
expect people to see exactly how the
game is going to end i don't know how
the game is going to end
but what you need to understand is that
white has an unlimited amount of time
due to the paralysis the black is
experiencing why it is an unlimited
amount of time to bring all of the rest
of the pieces into the game this is
something a lot of players i think have
a hard time understanding because when
they see
a computer evaluating the position as
winning they think well there must be
something by force there must be some
sacrifice or some mating combination but
that's not always the case it could just
be winning because uh one side is
paralyzed and the other has in the long
run a crushing attack
okay
um
well the night gets unstuck but it
doesn't matter because you're taking all
of black spawns i mean by all means be
my guest you know take here and give me
these give me this pawn center
um
so
it's so active and it's crushing
there is also the move rook to b3 here
that is an alternative and this also
leads to a winning position for white
and it does so in a very similar manner
rook b3 and now you simply play e4
i think this is a tiny bit less
convincing because at least black gets a
chance to develop
uh some pieces
but now there's an amazing move bishop
to b5
there's an amazing move bishop to b5
this has only been played in one game
and the idea is that after a6 to chase
away the bishop you respond with a3
okay so you might be like but wait a
second why not go a3
in in this position why is bishop b5
necessary
um the reason is because
after bishop takes c3 bishop takes c3
black has to move queen to a4
where the queen is at least parked on a
nice square and attacking you for so you
play bishop b5 much like we played queen
c1 in the game to deprive the queen
preliminarily of its key escape square
on a4
then after a6 we counter attack the
bishop with a3 this of course relies on
some tactics in order to work
so if
so the whole point of this is that if if
black now plays bishop c3 notice how
this bishop stops the queen from coming
out to a4
if black plays a takes b5 which happened
in the game that this occurred in then
after a takes before look at how
terrible the queen is going to be you
can't take this pawn because of the pin
uh black dropped the queen to a6 and
after castles black was completely lost
cast and black won the game somehow
castles castles
and um
black is totally paralyzed in fact the
computer indicates an insane move bishop
back to c1
in order to prevent black from
liberating his
liberating position with d6
uh
and there's a million attacking ideas
here knight d5 is coming this is plus
five
black is completely and utterly
paralyzed okay both players were 2 000
so white made some mistakes a little bit
later
um
in the game white played queen to e2
which is already very inaccurate
so this is goater against biro world
senior championship bucharest 2019
so i was very i'm very impressed at how
white has played so far but queenie ii
is a big mistake because what does it
allow black to do
what does it allow black to do and after
black's next move black is already okay
black was 2147.
yeah so black liberates the position
with d6 i think white was too transfixed
on taking this pawn without realizing
why i missed the forest for the trees
because now the bishop is coming out to
g4
and so the move bishop c1 is an
incredible prophylactic move
but this also threatens rook a3 which
wins the which essentially wins the rook
so that would have been the most precise
winning move but that's why i think rook
b3 is a little bit less
convincing i much prefer the move knight
d5 and so that's a little bit of an
expose in the england our opponent
played queen a5 and blundered the bishop
which wins the game immediately thank
you lily karinso for the raid with the
party of 72. i really appreciate it
um
one second
yeah i hope that this isn't too
technical i know that some of you don't
play 1d4
and um
welcome guys we're finishing up a
speedrun thank you lily
and uh at the end of the day i mean this
is just completely losing quinn a2e4
developing covering the e6 square
covering the b2 square look at how our
pieces are cooperating and then we
trapped the queen and he resigned
could you have feed kid of the light
square bishop here yeah that's possible
thank you for the 500 god nug
um
any questions about this game now this
is how the game actually ended
can black play bishop a5 instead of
trading bishops yes so bishop a5 is
possible
um
bishop a5 is definitely possible
but then again white just plays
oh the move that i have is rook to b5
yeah this is this is a good move because
this threatens bishop takes a5 and
knight takes c7 and essentially forces
the same type of position as
as we just looked at so rook b5 takes
takes
and if king to d8
then again you just play e4 it doesn't
really matter where the rook is the rook
could always drop back down to b3 in
case of necessity
and so
in conclusion i highly
advise against the england i think the
england
if you want to play
offbeat openings there are many offbeat
openings that are much better than the
young one that are more reputable and
allow you to experience a wider range of
positions
um
you know some of them there is the
budapest gambit which does rely on white
playing the main line that's e5
you could play many different off-beat
fb lines with d5 you've seen me play the
baltic teach this to hafu the chagoran
you can play the album counter gambit
with e5 all of these are far more
reputable in the album sorry then the
england
and uh you always have to strike a
balance if you want to play offbeat
openings that's fine but what you don't
want to do is play an opening where if
your opponent knows what to do
you're
you know basically just totally lost you
again you you want to find something
that exposes you to different types of
positions not something which is so
gimmicky that it only works against one
type of sequence
well i did play knight f3 i did play
that f3
that's that's what
happened um i hope i'm not stepping on i
hope nobody's
wait what do you mean already beer
how is it equal material it's upon
sacrifice
i mean didn't we just sort of
where in which line are you surprised
that it's plus two plus three
yeah i hope nobody like seriously
recommends the england because
i don't know i
in my opinion it's it's just not
not tenable
okay but i think levy's probably
trolling i don't i don't
anticipate
well artibia as i explained here the
badness of the england
is that it gives white a tremendous
a tremendous development advantage
um and the king is chronically weak like
this is why the england is bad the lines
that i just showed this is the main line
of the england and as you could see i
hope i did a halfway decent job of
explaining why white's attacking that
line is so overwhelming
uh but i don't recommend it even for
beginners again when i recommend
something what's up valentinian
uh when i recommend something or advice
against something i'm certainly not
trying to dis
any i'm certainly not trying to diss
anybody
who does recommended you make your own
choices you you find what works for you
um
you totally find what works for you
and i want to make that super clear
i can only
you know tell stuff from the bottom of
my heart i mean i i'm just being honest
about what i think people
should consider playing if you want to
improve as quickly as possible
but if there's other people who do
recommend it
my motivation here is not to uh
you know
not to not to diss them or to suggest
that i know better there is no right or
wrong approach here everybody has their
own path
okay
[Music]
you